ihr erinnert euch sicher alle an diese
tragischen Bilder eine Atomkatastrophe
die sich vor mehr als einem Jahrzehnt
ereignet hat
der Unfall im Kernkraftwerk Fukushima 1
war eine Folge des gewaltigen TS der
nach dem großen Seebeben am 11 märz 2011
japanische Ostküste verwüstete die
Nuklearkatastrophe Weg die schlimmsten
Erinnerungen an den verheerenden
Tschernobyl-Unfall letztendlich war
dieser Unfall zwar nicht annähernd so
schwerwiegend wie jeder 1986 in der
heutigen Ukraine dennoch müsste auf der
ganzen Welt eine heftige Bewegung gegen
die Atomkraft aus der Wettlauf viele
Länder sich nach Fukushima von dieser
Art der Energiegewinnung los zu sagen
erinnerte an ein Olympia Finale im 100 m
Lauf das war vor elf Jahren jetzt ganz
aktuell stehen wir fast überall auf der
Welt vor einer großen Energiekrise daran
ist zwar der Kernenergieausstieg einige
Länder mit Sicherheit nicht der
Hauptschuldige aber sein cheflein hat
auch er dazu beigetragen wir wollen
heute aber weder den Atomausstieg der
damaligen deutschen Merkel Regierung
hinterfragen noch die grüne Energiewende
Putins Gaspipeline Poker seinen Ukraine
Krieg die Pandemie folgen und den
Klimawandel durchleuchten also alles was
die ursächlich mit unseren akuten
Energieproblemen zu tun hat nein diese
Generalabrechnung sparen wir uns für ein
eigenes Video auf ihr dürft da durchaus
schon mal gespannt sein also Abo und
Glöckchen nicht vergessen um es nicht zu
verpassen heute wollen wir uns jedoch
anschauen was denn eigentlich aus der
Atomkraft im Land der aufgehenden Sonne
geworden ist und was man nun damit dort
erstaunliches vorhat denn wenn Japan mit
einer neuen Entwicklung im
atomenergie-sektor Erfolg haben sollte
könnte dies einem anderen Energieträger
der Zukunft mächtig nach vorne verhelfen
die Rede ist von Wasserstoff aber wie
wir es bei visualpolitik lieben nicht so
eilig und immer schön der Reihe nach
nach dem fukushima-unfall wurden in
Japan die 50 Atomreaktoren des Landes
allesamt erst einmal abgeschaltet bei
einigen hatte das Erdbeben ebenfalls
Störfälle verursacht bis heute wurden 21
Reaktoren stillgelegt und nur noch zehn
sind aktiv die übrigen stehen immer noch
still und warten darauf dass über ihre
Zukunft entschieden wird erneuerbare
Energien aber auch Kohle total
Flüssiggas haben die Kapazitäten Japans
eines riesige atomstromgewinnung ersetzt
in folgender Grafik könnt ihr sehen wie
sich der japanische Energie Mix seit den
verhängnisvollen Unfall von 2011
verändert hat wie ihr seht hat das
atomoratorium dazu geführt dass er
Verbrauch von Kohle und Erdgas zu
Stromerzeugung in die Höhe geschossen
ist wer sich also vorrangig Sorgen um
die CO2-Emissionen macht muss sich die
Haare raufen
eine andere tatsache ist aber auch dass
der Mangel an Investitionen im
Energiesektor in den letzten Jahren und
nun akut die Folgen des russischen
einmaliges in der Ukraine die
Erdgaspreise in die Höhe schnellen
ließen und zwar so stark dass ihr euch
allesamt werde Japaner unter Garantie
auch die Haare raufen würdet nun aber
schon allein wegen der Höhe eurer Strom
und Heizkostenabrechnung diese beiden
Umstände erklären aber warum der jetzt
mehr als ein Jahrzehnt nach Fukushima
Nachrichten wie diese lesen können
Japan kehrten nach Fukushima zur
Atomkraft zurück die wieder in
Betriebnahme der japanischen
Kernkraftwerke wäre geeignet erhebliche
Mengen an LNG für den Weltmarkt
freizusetzen
durch den einmal Russland in der Ukraine
hat sich die globale Energie Situation
drastisch verändert Romeo kishida
Premierminister Japans tja tatsache ist
das Japan beschlossen hat sich wieder
freudig in die Arme der Atomindustrie zu
werfen
da stellt sich uns aber schon die Frage
wie ist eigentlich möglich ist das
ausgerechnet jedes Land das vor gar
nicht so langer Zeit das große
anti-atomografieber ausgelöst hat nun
gerade zu Schrittmacher bei der
Wiederbelebung dieser Energietechnologie
ist auf welche innovative Weise möchte
Japan in einem ganz neues Atomzeitalter
eintreten und wichtiger noch inwieweit
markiert diese Entscheidung Japans einen
Wendepunkt im globalen Energie-System
all das und noch viel mehr verraten wir
euch in diesem Video bevor wir jedoch
loslegen muss ich noch kurz Werbung
machen für zwei wichtige Dinge und diese
sind nicht nur für uns wichtig sondern
auch für euch nun zum einen würde ich
euch gerne darum bitten euch unsere
neuen Kanal visual economic.de anzusehen
falls ihr ihn noch nicht abonniert habt
[Musik]
auf visual economic geht es um spannende
Hintergründe aus der Welt der Wirtschaft
und ich denke dass unsere neuen Videos
dort durchaus sehenswert sind
schließlich sind sie beim Publikum schon
gleich zu Anfang sehr gut angekommen
alle die schon dabei sind möchten wir
hier daher nochmals herzlich danken und
falls ihr es noch nicht seid findet ihr
den Link zur visuale.de über das i oben
rechts und in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video also lasst euch unseren
neuen Kanal auf keinen Fall entgehen ich
danke euch die zweite wichtige Sache die
ich euch ans Herz legen möchte ist
Passwortsicherheit ein Thema das viel zu
viele leider immer noch auf die leichte
Schulter nehmen dabei kann das sichere
Umgang mit Passwörtern doch so einfach
sein zum Beispiel mit Hilfe unseres
tollen Sponsors nordpass worum es bei
nordpass geht nun hast du z.B einen
Überblick darüber wie viele
Benutzernamen und Passwörter du in
letzter Zeit erstellt hast ich meine
Websites Anwendungen E-Mails und so
weiter ich wette dass du mittlerweile
eine riesige Menge an Passwort und für
all diese Dienste angehäuft hast oder
aber du hast die kardinalsünde begangen
und dasselbe Passwort mehr als benutzt
komm schon ich wette das hast du auch
schon getan es ist normal dass wir
aufgrund von Zeitdruck oder schierer
Faulheit zu einfacher Passwörter
verwenden oder diese gar recyceln tja
und jetzt kommt die unbequeme aber
leider umso erfolgreichere Wahrheit in
der heutigen Zeit können wir uns eine
solche Nachlässigkeit immer weniger
leisten und zwar keiner von uns denn wir
dürfen unsere Privatsphäre und auch
unsere private Sicherheit nicht aufs
Spiel setzen so und jetzt kommt die gute
Nachricht mit nordpass kannst du
automatische sichere Passwörter für
jedes deiner Kunden erstellen und sie an
einem Ort speichern ohne dass du sie dir
merken musst aber nicht nur das mit dem
Auto viel Feature kannst du dich überall
viel schneller einloggen ohne deine
Passwörter überhaupt eintippen zu müssen
darüber hinaus kannst du bis zu sechs
Geräte mit einem Account nutzen und
nordpass sorgt ganz automatisch dafür
dass deine Login-Daten überall
synchronisiert bleiben okay klingt ganz
nett nicht wahr nordpass geht jedoch
noch einen Schritt weiter und schützt
deine Daten nicht nur passiv sondern
auch proaktiv mit einem ganzen Arsenal
von security features
Maß premiums kennt zum Beispiel das
Internet kontinuierlich nach deinen
Daten ab und findet heraus ob diese
nicht möglicherweise gelegt wurden und
falls dies der Fall sein sollte wann es
nicht so dass Du rechtzeitig reagieren
und die Gefahr bannen kannst bevor
schlimmeres Unglück hereinbricht und das
Beste für die visualpolitik-community
hat nordpass eine ganz besondere Aktion
in petto ganze vier Monate kostenlose
Nutzung plus ein Sonderangebot über das
du alles erfährst wenn du den Link noch
passt Punkt kommst / visualpolitik
aufrufst den ich dir in die Beschreibung
unter diesem Video packe natürlich
kannst du alles in Ruhe unverbindlich
und völlig ohne Risiko ausprobieren denn
noch passt kommt mit einer 30-tägigen
Geld zurück Garantie falls es Dich bis
dahin nicht von seinen Vorzügen
überzeugen sollte also klickt jetzt auf
den Link und probiert nordpass aus um
eure private Sicherheit zu erhöhen ihr
greift damit auch uns finanziell unter
die Arme was ihr übrigens auch direkt
über den Spenden tun könnt der sich
ebenfalls unter den Video befindet so
und jetzt schnell ins Land der
aufgehenden Sonne wo wir uns sofort das
neue japanische Atomzeitalter ansehen
werden
es ist für uns alle kein großes
Geheimnis und auch keine Neuigkeit in
den letzten Jahren haben sich die
reichsten Bilder des Planeten auf ein
Plan Ziel gereinigt es geht um die
dekarbonisierung des Energieverbrauchs
also den weitestmöglichen Verzicht auf
die Klima schädliche Verbrennung von
Kohlenwasserstoffen aus diesem Plan
ergibt sich zwangsläufig eine bestimmte
Grundstrategie nämlich die massenhafte
Elektrifizierung unseres Lebensstils
Solarzellen auf dem Dach und Wärmepumpe
im Garten statt Gasbrenner im Keller
Elektromotor statt Dieselaggregat im
Auto nur um zwei Beispiele zu nennen
wenn wir also sowohl Wirtschaftswachstum
als auch diesen massiven
elektrifizierungsprozess anpeilen ergibt
sich dass die weltweite Stromnachfrage
in die Höhe schießen wird das zeigen
auch ganz klar Prognosen der
Internationalen Energieagentur konkret
wird erwartet dass der
Elektrizitätsbedarf von 23.000 Terabyte
Stunden im Jahr 2020 auf mehr als 60.000
im Jahr 2050 ansteigen wird mit anderen
Worten alles deutet darauf hin dass ich
die Stromnachfrage der nächsten 28
Jahren praktisch dreifachen wird anders
ausgedrückt und diese enorme Nachfrage
zu befriedigen müssen wir im Grunde die
gesamte stromerzeugungsinfrastruktur der
Welt um das Dreifache aufstocken und
zwar egal ob nun Gas Öl Kohle oder
Wasserkraftwerke oder die diversesten
Anlagen zur Nutzung erneuerbarer Energie
und könnt ihr euch das überhaupt
vorstellen es geht also nicht nur darum
fossile Brennstoffe durch saubere
Energien zu ersetzen sondern
gleichzeitig noch um eine Verdreifachung
der Kapazitäten zu Energieproduktion und
das meine lieben Freunde klingt gelinde
gesagt nach einer wirklich sehr großen
Sache
[Musik]
die Ausgangslage ist jedoch nennen wir
es mal vorsichtig sehr schwierig im Jahr
2021 machte die Stromerzeugung aus
fossilen drei Stunden also Kohle Gas und
Öl 60% der weltweiten Gesamtproduktion
aus für diejenigen die sich vorrangig
Sorgen um die Emissionen machen dabei
werden 13,8 GB Tonnen CO2 ausgestoßen
diese Emissionen wollen wir also
reduzieren den Klima zuliebe am liebsten
auf Null aber gleichzeitig gilt es
innerhalb von drei Jahrzehnten die
globale Stromerzeugungskapazität der
Welt zu verdreifachen und das klingt
nach einer unlösbaren Aufgabe warum nun
weil erneuerbare Energien wahrscheinlich
nicht in der Lage sein werden eine so
hohe Nachfrage nach Strom alleine zu
decken das liegt unter anderem daran
dass es sich dabei zu meist um Quellen
handelt die wie Sonnenschein oder Wind
nicht konstant zur Verfügung stehen und
daher immer eine reservequelle aus
fossilen Brennstoffen benötigt es ging
also nicht nur darum die Welt mit
Sonnenkollektoren und Windräder zu
pflastern sondern auch mit
Erdgaskraftwerken wir reden hier von
einer gigantischen investitionsleistung
die immer mehr Stimmen auf der Welt für
völlig undurchführbar halten zumindest
ohne die Reaktivierung der Atomkraft und
darunter befinden sich sogar Stimmen von
Leuten von denen ihr es vielleicht am
wenigsten erwartet
Finnlands grüne stehen jetzt gänzlich
zur Atomkraft
Greta Thunberg hält Abschalten von AKW
für Fehler die schwedische
klimaaktivistin würde auf Atomkraft
statt Kohle setzen um die Stromerzeugung
aus Gas zu reduzieren tja und ein
weiterer solcher Fall ist eben ihr habt
es erraten Japan aber bedeutet das nicht
die nächste Runde russischen Roulette
soll nun doch wieder die Kernenergie
ausgebaut werden bis uns eines Tages
vielleicht erneut irgendwo ein Reaktor
um die Ohren fliegt schon allein die
Tatsache dass momentan das riesige
ukrainische Kernkraftwerk saporicia
genau auf der Frontlinie liegt sich
Russlands unter teska auf dem Gelände
herumtreibt und dort mitunter Raketen
einschlagen und Brände ausbrechen oder
Strom ausfällt reicht ja eigentlich für
schlaflose Nächte und das Verlangen die
alten atomkraft nein danke Buttons
wieder hinten aus der Schublade
hervorzukramen aber die wäre es wenn die
zugegeben risikobehaftete Kernenergie
neben der reinen Stromerzeugung noch
andere verwertungszwecke haben könnte
wenn kein Energie der Schlüssel zur
Herstellung sehr Kraftstoffe sein könnte
die Benzin Diesel oder Kerosin in Autos
Lastwagen Schiffen und Flugzeugen
ersetzen könnte klingt fantastisch
bleibt dran wir kommen gleich darauf
zurück
[Musik]
atomkraft ja bitte
wie ich bereits erwähnt habe ist Japan
eines der Länder die angekündigt haben
dass sie ihr Engagement in der
Kernenergie wieder reaktivieren aber es
ist nicht das einzige
Polen endet Gesetze um Investitionen in
die Kernenergie zu beschleunigen im
September letzten Jahres wurde bekannt
dass bis 20406 große
Druckwasserreaktoren mit einer
Gesamtleistung von 6 bis 9
Gigawattstunden gebaut werden könnten um
die starke kohleabhängigkeit Polens zu
verringern
[Musik]
südkorea will Atomkraft auf ein Drittel
der Energieversorgung erhöhen das Ziel
übertrifft die Vorgaben des
oecd-ausschusses für nukleare
Entwicklung
macron frankreich will bis 2050 bis zu
14 neue Atomreaktoren bauen die
Kernenergie erlebt gerade ein
unglaublich starkes Comeback allein
china will in den nächsten 15 bis 20
Jahren rund 400 Milliarden Dollar
passieren um haltet euch fest 150 neue
Atomreaktoren zu bauen und über die
Renaissance des Atoms in Südkorea haben
wir erst vor kurzem ein Video
herausgebracht
[Musik]
wie ihr seht also es geht hier nicht nur
um Japan aber was Japan zu einem
Sonderfall macht ist nicht nur das ist
im letzten Jahrzehnt eines der Länder
war dass der Atomkraft besonders
kritisch gegenüber stand denn zugleich
weiß auch schon vor Fukushima immer
eines der Länder mit einer besonders
intensivbetriebenen Forschung im Bereich
der Atomtechnologie und dank diesen
Forschungsanstrengungen verfügt Japan in
der Präfektur über Raki über den
sogenannten
project Engineering Test reactor kurz
htta oder auf gut Deutsch in einem
ellenlangen Wort Hochtemperatur Technik
testreaktor und dieser könnte zumindest
nach japanischer Überzeugung das Vorbild
für einen Reaktortyp sein der
langfristig die Zukunft der Kernenergie
im ganzen Land prägen wird die Rede ist
von den sogenannten kleinen modularen
Reaktoren kurz SMA und das überraschende
der HGT ist seit über zwei Jahrzehnten
in Betrieb handelt es sich also um
Alteisen von wegen erst jetzt scheint
seine Zeit gekommen zu sein denn
aufgepasst seine Funktion muss ich auf
die Stromerzeugung beschränken
[Musik]
die erste technische Besonderheit dieses
mit Helium gekühlten Reaktors ist dass
er kein Wasser benötigt das bedeutet
zunächst einmal dass er praktisch
überall auf der Erde aufgestellt werden
könnte sonst brauchen Kernkraftwerke
immer sehr viel Wasser zur Kühlung und
stehen deshalb an Küsten oder großen
Flüssen und schon das kann ja ein
Problem sein siehe die Tsunami Gefahr
oder die üble Dürre die Frankreichs AKWs
förmlich trocken legte zudem kann der
Kern eines stta aufgrund seiner Bauweise
nicht schmelzen technologisch handelt es
sich also um eine Revolution außerdem
und das ist jetzt sehr wichtig kann
diese Technologie bei sehr hohen
Temperaturen arbeiten bei über 900 Grad
Celsius und mit dieser Hitze und dem
dabei erzeugten Strom kann sie große
Mengen an Wasserstoff produzieren ja ihr
habt richtig gehört Wasserstoff auf
visualpolitik haben wir in einem
früheren Video schon einmal über dieses
chemische Element gesprochen dort haben
erzählt dass es drei Haupttypen von
Wasserstoff als Energieträger gibt
grauen blauen und grünen um es kurz zu
rekapitulieren grauer Wasserstoff wird
aus Kohle gewonnen blaue aus Erdgas und
grüner aus Wasser aber mittels
erneuerbare Energien letzterer ist dann
schön ökologisch aber Bahn witzig teuer
die Wahrheit ist jedoch das ist noch
eine vierte Art von Wasserstoff als
Energieträger gibt den rosa Wasserstoff
das ist jeder der mit Hilfe von
Kernenergie hergestellt wird und wie wir
euch in einem anderen Video schon
berichtet haben ist Japan eines jener
Länder die das Thema Wasserstoff als
Energieträger sehr ernst nehmen für die
Japaner ist das keine fixe Idee oder
futuristischer Wunschtraum sondern
zunehmend Realität wenn ihr mehr dazu
wissen wollt schaut euch unser Video vom
letzten Jahr zum Thema
methanhydratförderung und
Wasserstoffwirtschaft in Japan ruhig
noch mal an den Link dazu findet ihr
unten in der Beschreibung
[Musik]
nun also kreuzen sich bei den Japanern
zwei Entwicklungslinien von
Zukunftstechnologien die
Wasserstoffwirtschaft einerseits und das
zivile Atomprogramm andererseits Japans
im Oktober 2021 verabschiedeter
strategische Energieplan sieht vor das
genau diese Art von Helium gekühlten
Hochtemperatur Kernreaktoren zur
Herstellung von Wasserstoff eingesetzt
werden sollen außerdem heißt es in
Japans im Juni 2021 verabschiedeten
Strategie für grünes Wachstum zu
erreichen der kohlenstoffneutralität bis
2050 das htta Reaktoren erforderlich
sein werden um ab 2030 emissionsfreien
Wasserstoff in großen Mengen und zu
geringen Kosten zu produzieren und 2030
heißt in Bezug auf strategische
Energieinfrastruktur so viel wie
übermorgen denn mit den dafür
notwendigen Investitionen muss so
schnell wie möglich begonnen werden
[Musik]
und ihr seht das diese neue Anwendung
bei der nicht nur Strom sondern auch
große Mengen an emissionsfreien
Wasserstoff erzeugt werden der
Kernenergie eine neue Rolle geben könnte
die sie bisher nicht Inhalte das würde
einen weiteren Aufschwung für diese
Branche bedeuten und Sicherheit keinen
kleinen allerdings hat sich viele von
euch schon fragen halt warum ist
Wasserstoff jetzt eigentlich so wichtig
für uns tja einfach deshalb weil immer
mehr Experten darin einen Kraftstoff
sehen der dich Verwendung von Benzin
Diesel oder Kerosin in der Industrie im
gütertransporter der Schifffahrt und
sogar ein Flugverkehr ersetzen kann ein
potenziell sauberer und unbegrenzt
vorhandene Kraftstoff der sogar als
Batterie also als Energiespeicher
verwendet werden könnte
[Musik]
und die Internationale Energieagentur
geht davon aus dass deren Jahr 2020 noch
etwa 90 Millionen Tonnen Wasserstoff
produziert wurden die Produktion bis
2050 mindestens 500 Millionen Tonnen
erreichen wird das Problem ist das
derzeit nur zehn Prozent der
Wasserstoffproduktion sauber sind wenn
also die Missionsziele erreicht werden
sollen wird eine Menge billige
emissions-trainer Energie benötigt um
den ständig steigenden Energiebedarf zu
decken denn auf diese Weise könnte man
sich auch den aufwändigen Transport des
Wasserstoffs an seinen
verwendungsbausparen der Energieträger
wird genau dort erzeugt wo er auch
gebraucht wird und das ist noch nicht
alles wir sind noch lange nicht am Ende
der Geschichte es geht nämlich nicht nur
um Wasserstoff
[Applaus]
die Kernenergie könnte auch für die
Herstellung anderer synthetischer
Brennstoffe nützlich sein und in Japan
untersucht man zudem wie die in den
Reaktoren erzeugt Wärme in
fernwärmesysteme kanalisiert werden auf
diese Weise könnten die neuen
Kernreaktoren also drei Ziele auf einmal
erfüllen Stromproduktion die Herstellung
von Wasserstoff und synthetischen
Kraftstoffen und die Versorgung von
Heizsystemen und das alles ohne auch nur
ein einziges Gramm CO2 in die Atmosphäre
zu blasen ist doch unglaublich nicht
wahr so gesehen ist es kein Wunder dass
ich jetzt viele Länder und Experten für
diesen neuen Trend interessieren aber
viele von euch denken jetzt wohl auch
Markt du siehst die kein Energie durch
deine rosarote Brille und jetzt ist dein
Blick noch dazu von Rosa Wasserstoff
vernebelt weißt du nicht dass der Bau
von Atomkraftwerken ewig dauert und
extrem teuer ist das alles bis 2050 zu
schaffen ist doch ein Ding der
Unmöglichkeit tja in gewisser Weise habt
ihr da recht allerdings gibt es wieder
ein paar los schaut mal
nur die schnellen steigen auf die
langsamen stürzen ab
in den Kommentaren werden wir ja oft um
einen Blick hinter die Kulissen gebeten
und heute möchte ich euch passend zum
Thema einen solchen kleinen Gewehren
schauen wir doch mal welches Buch ich
doch immer im Regal stehen habe
tja es ist
heumer von ditforce im Anfang war der
Wasserstoff ein Buch das wohl wie kaum
ein anderes mein persönliches Weltbild
geprägt hat werft mal einen Blick auf
diese Grafik
was ihr hier seht ist die minimale die
durchschnittliche und die maximale Zeit
die jedes Land mit Kernenergie für den
Bau seiner AKWs gebraucht hat wie ihr
seht haben Länder wie Argentinien oder
die USA Kraftwerke deren Bau Ost
unterschiedlichen Gründen über 20 Jahre
gedauert hat das ist schon ziemlich irre
aber schauen wir uns doch mal das andere
Ende des Diagramms an Japan ist das Land
in den Kraftwerke am schnellsten gebaut
werden seit etwa 40 Jahren haben seine
Anlagen eine durchschnittliche Bauzeit
von 3 bis 5 Jahren andere Länder wie
Südkorea schaffen mit durchschnittlich 6
Jahren ebenfalls ansehnliche fristen
[Musik]
da stellt sich die Frage warum es so
große Unterschiede bei den Bauzeiten
gibt nun hier stoßen wir auf viele große
und kleine Dilemmas und Schwierigkeiten
mit denen diese Technologie vor allem im
Westen belastet ist zum einen wäre da
die westliche Atomindustrie insbesondere
die europäische sie ist nach Jahren
massiver Unterfinanzierung ganz
allgemein in eine Schieflage geraten wir
sprechen hier von innovationsdefiziten
aber auch von Problemen mit Lieferketten
und das ist kein Wunder wenn du keine
Kraftwerke baust kannst du auch nicht
erwarten dass Zulieferer für die nötigen
Komponenten parat stehen zum anderen ist
da die Frage der Regulierung und der
bürokratischen Hürden selbst in jedem
Ländern die noch neue Atomkraftwerke
zulassen ist der Zeitaufwand für die
Erteilung von Genehmigungen
Umweltstudien und Risikoanalysen enorm
schon allein die Auswahl eines
geeigneten Standorts kann sich mächtig
hinziehen denn in den letzten
Jahrzehnten war die Atomkraft zum
Beispiel in Deutschland und Österreich
alles andere als beliebt irgendwie
möchte niemand ein AKW direkt vor seiner
eigenen Haustür stehen haben und
natürlich sind die Kosten umso höher je
länger die Vorlaufzeit für
auswahlplanung Regulierung und Bau ist
das alles in Fragen die unbedingt gelöst
werden müssen und ob die Europäer dies
schaffen ist offen
[Musik]
eines scheint jedoch klar die
Kernenergie feiert ein absolutes Revival
Japan als Vorreiter hat sein
Atommoratorium rückgängig gemacht und
will nun mit voller Kraft in diese
Technologie einsteigen China Südkorea
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
Großbritannien Finnland Polen und viele
andere Länder gehen in die gleiche
Richtung alles deutet darauf hin dass
wir erst am Anfang einer neuen Welle im
energie-sektor Stehen nun werden
sicherlich viele einbinden das ist eben
nur eine Welle ist und angesichts
unserer technologischen bürokratischen
babykeit daraus wohl kaum so schnell ein
mächtiger Brecher würde alles da gewesen
in der europäischen Energiewirtschaft
wegspült oder gar kurz und kleinen Haut
wieder verheerende Tsunami von 2011 mit
dem unsere Geschichte heute angefangen
hat niemand in Japan hatte damals real
mit einer solchen Wellenhöhe und solchen
Verwüstungen gerechnet Auslöser des
Tsunamis war ein gewaltiges unter
seelisches Erdbeben vor der Küste mit
einer in Japan noch nie gemessenen
Stärke doch sollte sich der Klima Geld
für uns alle zu solch einer verheerenden
Magnitude Aufschaukeln könnte er
durchaus verfolgen und Veränderungen
sorgen Veränderungen die wir uns heute
noch nicht so recht vorstellen können
oder wollen fakt bleibt Kernenergie kann
mal ganz unabhängig betrachtet von all
ihren Risiken Nöten Kosten und Altlast
und Entsorgungsproblemen reichlich und
Billigstrom liefern und in Zukunft auch
Wasserstoff und Wärme und das ist in der
heutigen energiekrisenzeit ja schon eine
ganze Menge das wollen wir hier erstmal
als Fazit stehen lassen auch wenn du uns
in zukünftigen Videos noch oft mit dem
Thema Kernenergie beschäftigen werden
denn jetzt seid ihr an der Reihe würdet
ihr wollen dass eure Länder mehr im
Kernenergie investieren was haltet ihr
von der Idee kleine sichere modulare
Reaktoren der zentral in der Nähe von
Städten und großen Industriezentren zu
bauen und was haltet ihr vom rosa
Wasserstoff hinterlasst uns unter dem
Video bitte eure Kommentare und wenn ihr
dieses Video interessant fandet bitte
bitte nicht vergessen uns dafür ein Like
zu geben es mit euren Freunden zu teilen
und falls ihr das noch nicht getan habt
privatpolitik zu abonnieren natürlich
mit den Glöckchen testet bitte auch
unverbindlich das Angebot unseres
heutigen Sponsors Nordpols der für die
visuality Community eine ganz besondere
Aktion bietet vier Monate kostenlose
Nutzung plus ein Sonderangebot über das
noch alles erfährst wenn du den Link
dort
passt.com/visualpolitik aufrufst den ich
euch in die Beschreibung unter diesem
Video packe natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit der uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den paypalink dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]